welcome to the man of Recaps this is The
Walking Dead season 11 episode 23. so
Alexandria has been liberated by our
gang but they're not sticking around
they're going back to the Commonwealth
gotta rescue their kids but also you
know lead a revolution Daryl and Carol
Tell Young Judith Grimes to stay here
and watch her brother but Judith is like
absolutely not I'm the little ass kicker
I'm coming to fight and yes she is the
best of everyone biological daughter of
Rick and or Shane and Laurie raised by
Michonne and Daryl and Carol and the
whole group at large so they're like you
know what absolutely you're in now we've
heard about the train from Alexandria to
the Commonwealth and yeah our group's
got it taking a little train ride into
the big city back at the Commonwealth
Eugene is still alive because Mercer let
him go he's finally ready to join the
resistance it's like Eugene you lay low
while I gather troops you know that are
loyal to me ready to make a move against
Pamela Milton but as he's making his
report to Pamela he can't hide that he
doesn't like her anymore Pamela
absolutely knows he's up to something so
she sends this other guard to keep an
eye on him and the whole Commonwealth is
still in the state of civil unrest
protesting about Eugene's verdict and
now it's confirmed what we kind of
suspected that Pamela Milton calls in in
a zombie horde to be rounded up towards
the Commonwealth so she has an excuse to
call a lockdown disperse everyone in
this herd is the rest of our outside
crew Aaron Lydia and all the rest when
they pass by an RV it's like this is our
shot let's hide but Luke's girlfriend
Jules gets swept away oh no he's like
well I'm going with her and also Lydia's
new boyfriend Elijah is getting swept
away too she's like no man I got you but
as a former Whisperer she should know
better cause our zombie bites her arm
luckily she's in here now with Aaron the
expert in losing an arm it's like yeah
girl sorry this is gonna hurt but tell
Lydia's amputated but when she comes to
she still feels real guilty about Elijah
and the others being swept away she's
like we gotta go after him so it's Jerry
Who's like all right I'm gonna check on
him and oh no the way he's saying
goodbye here it really seems like he's
gonna die not Jerry please he's the best
but I guess we are coming up to the
finale some beloved characters will have
to go anyway the train crew manages to
contact Mercer his girlfriend princess
is like hey are you actually with us now
he's like yeah girl I am he's gonna go
let them in the back gate but just now
the alarm's blaring cause the zombie
herd is approaching so Mercy's got go
deal with that but he does manage to
call the guards on the back gate like
hey come on help us fight the zombies
but now Pamela Milton is fully on to him
so when our crew gets up into the train
station oh it's an ambush so inside the
train station it's an epic shootout oh
blah blah blam and Pamela Milton's real
mad at this crew she comes to join the
fun herself she lines up for a shot at
Maggie but little due to the Grimes
blocks the way and oh gets shot this
makes our group real mad their fight
with Newfound ferocity and it's time to
bust out a sick move Ezekiel throws the
fire extinguisher Daryl blam meanwhile
at the border it should be a routine
zombie herd cleanup but things are not
going well cause this zombies grab it
onto the truck and Justin Pamela's
guards come to a rest immersive treason
it's like all right I'll go but please
deal with the zombies but with all these
troops on other missions and Mercer
arrested the wall is unguarded that
shouldn't matter I mean what are the
zombies gonna do climb it but yeah as
we've seen we got some variants out
there who have learned how to climb
that's exactly what they do and you know
things always go bad this guy
accidentally opens the gate and now the
zombie horde is swarming into the
Commonwealth Pamela Milton's a bit in
shock that her political distraction has
now turned into a life-threatening
situation her new general proposes a
plan to save as much of the city as they
can but Pamela pulls an attack on Titan
she's like forget all that abandon the
outer ring all troops guarding the rich
people's neighborhood they're not worth
saving let the poor get eaten so is our
crews running from Commonwealth soldiers
they're getting penned in but it's like
wait these soldiers aren't after us and
oh man we're on the wrong side of the
barricades the zombies are swarming so
our group is pending fighting for their
lives Daryl's got little Judith who is
bleeding out he's like Priority One I
gotta get her to the hospital and so
after a few episodes of Meandering we
are now getting to an actually super
exciting climax how will The Walking
Dead come to an end find out next week
on the series finale
if you liked this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and movies
[Music]